e aí galera assim o cantor ele tem
alguma coisa errada aqui aí agora sim eu
pergunto por que entrava sem camisa que
faz calor desgraça língua quanto faz o
ada barulho ar condicionado o pessoal de
vila velha no espírito santo dia 6 de
novembro eu tô fazendo show e e em são
mateus do espírito santo 17 de novembro
fazem show em comprar seu ingresso para
o show muito legal a senhora esse site
aqui valeu e nós eu falei aqui no
facebook galera vou gravar um vídeo
respondendo perguntas faça suas
perguntas dos comentários já sabemos
nada mais nada menos do que 51 mil
perguntas
então vamos às perguntas a ele pereira
pergunto você esperar fazer tanto
sucesso sim mas é claro agora que é
melhor um pouquinho bom o melhor eo mais
modesto também o ângelo carvalho pinto o
que é que tu fez que acho que não
deveria ter feito a primeira coisa que
eu fiz eu acho que não deveria ter feito
era ter saído do ovo do meu pai joyce
oliveira perto windows nessa sua
trajetória da carreira o que mais te
marcou até hoje o que mais me marcou até
hoje foi uma queda que eu levei que a
luz cutuvelo aqui até hoje está marcado
aqui o projecto farol inventou o macho
como é que um cego sabe se está limpo
depois de cá alguém aviso e segue segue
a possível na hora e foi pago é de lei
cunha pergunto qual é a sensação de ter
um nome esquisito é dinei essa sensação
acho que você deve saber porque é de 68
sabe que não num top da terra não
ninguém nunca na vida vai escutar assim
é óscar cardozo eo cunhado no máximo
pedindo é que 2 em quadra vai ai do site
nelas um tac os sanduíches uma teu
cabelo e perguntou por que se deve usar
uma agulha é esterilizada cada uma
injeção letal é um condenado à morte
ocorreu disse mackay cara enchendo o que
eu estou pensando por que a ingestão
tentar especializada tem que ser limpa
se o cara já vai morrer mateus é porque
tem que valer a pena o trabalho do cara
que da injeção de us 9
eu cá vai pega uma agulha usava a água
suja aí da injeção letal no cara ao
caramori vão fazer o laudo prova de que
o pai morreu a instalar a causa da morte
ainda não foi o cara que matou tão
focada em gestão e não cumprir o
trabalho dele o carro vai ser o que é
despedido senhor foi o que deixa são meu
trabalho está feito há cerca de 900 para
morrer de asw da licença que vai abrir a
vaga que é e nem cunha pode vir
trabalhar aqui o yuri alencar perguntou
como você se sente sendo um dos maiores
vultos do brasil e como você lida com o
preconceito de algumas pessoas que ainda
têm por nordestinos recinto fosse a cara
e se possível fosse assim tão bem às
vezes até esqueço que eu lembro que eu
sou alguma coisa assim por alguém tirar
a foto como eu lido com preconceito
eleito com preconceito assim o natanael
lima perguntou você já acabou no mato
que eu já caí num ato caguei que mais
apanhou já nem tanto no mapa é perigoso
twitter anonimato pizarro gosta minha
casa não mata a melhor coisa que tem é
muito melhor que na privada porque se
sente melhor e do matinhos ea coca as
gralhas de pau que fica atrás não
fazendo massagem no kukukaya um laptop
não matei o time criar uma tensão que
toque sublime um bibelô repente o
windows ou você já apanhou na escola já
apanhei apanhei mas ninguém o capitão
piso num dia no outro dia peguei uma
bota garra do bicos onde ferro grande
furg bota falei quando cheguei lá vou
meter o funaná de se falar da [ __ ] aí
cheguei lá e mandou tirar a bota e me
bater de novo o chile é o mc joão tex do
que não é esse meu filho daniel em
seguida perguntou já comeu um gay não
porque porque eu não sou gay e quem com
gay é gay porque tem que dizer não mas
eu não sou viável porque eu só com
goleiro não tem desculpa e cortou a
chapeleira da rua no cu do homem é
[ __ ] joão mário pergunta o endereço
se um jacaré solta pipa e um elefante
joga bola com dois tatu quem roubou
minha bicicleta que o teu seletivo
uma capivara do estado a página godoy
disse por que você não pedi um vidro e
me dá
seria um prazer ficar sentindo o
cheirinho do seu pedro era a minha vez
tentar muito enganado acho que o pedro
boticário e um filho faustão perdeu mas
também contra o peito a última vez que
eu perdi eu deixei 189
mil crianças desabrigadas joyce oliveira
perguntou o que é que tu acha da msc
melody que vocês acham que a américa
está a fazer um falsete é a pessoa que
acha que a américa está fazendo um
falsete ela muito escutou o cantor de
mala sem alça
quero aqui do meu lado apenas meninada
mas só tem 17 eu tenho
tô
é isso aí é que foi ouvido de hoje você
tiver o estado é seguido da china que o
youtube seja saber que fazer né bateu
recorde de lá é só clicar gostei aqui em
baixo os 21 média de 300 mil likes 310
milagre
vamos até à meta vamos passar os 400.000
league neste vídeo a equipe sofre pra
vocês só brincadeira se passar dos 400
mil likes no primeiro dia
amanhã tem vídeo novo de novo olha lá no
facebook eu postei vídeo novo nova para
você quer aplicar em curtir marcou amigo
seu se clicar aqui embaixo inscrever se
e nunca vai perder nenhum vídeo valeu é
nice e pelo em em futebol